this video is made possible by Vince
arrow watches luxury handcrafted watches
but at fair prices you can check them
out of Vince arrow watches dot-com /by
graphics more on them in a bit during
the 13th century a merchant named Marco
Polo returns home to Italy after
spending 24 years living in the
Mongolian Empire he had the bad luck of
getting arrested in genoa while they
were at war with his hometown of Venice
he was a prisoner for two years and he
just happened to share his cell with a
famous writer named rooster chela de
Pisa
the two of them shared stories with one
another as you do when you're stuck in a
prison cell with absolutely no form of
entertainment
mr. cello was so captivated by the
stories of Marco Polo's journey that he
knew that it would make a great book so
they spent those two years in captivity
writing the manuscript together when
they were released from prison they
published the travels of Marco Polo and
it became an overnight bestseller Marco
Polo became the first European to
document so many details about the
Mongolian and Chinese empires the
Western world had a difficult time
believing that it was possible that
there could be a civilization out there
that was actually more advanced than
theirs
his stories they were so fantastic the
people assumed that it was a work of
fiction for the rest of his life marco
polo he was called a liar he would take
hundreds of years before the world would
know that every single story he told was
absolutely true and yet even today there
are some skeptics who find it hard to
believe that one man could have seen and
done so much in his lifetime but he has
still gone down in history as being one
of the greatest explorers in the world
Marco Polo was born into a wealthy
venetian family in the year 1250 for he
was expected to follow the family trade
of becoming and merchants his father
Niccolo and his uncle Maffeo were
travelling most of Marco's young life
unlike a normal job merchants were
expected to leave home for years at a
time they travelled the world and they
gathered popular items like spices
pearls gold and gemstones that were
plentiful in certain countries they then
sold these Goods in other countries
where they were more valuable they would
earn enough money to last for years and
then again set out on a new journey at
that time travelers would return to
Europe claiming that they had seen
amazing creatures in the Far East
many of these they were complete works
of fiction there were stories about a
country full of human dog hybrids
fire-breathing dragons and mystical
unicorns Christians believe that the
Garden of Eden was somewhere hiding in
the Middle East and that Jerusalem was
located in the exact center of the world
a lot of people either fully believed
these fairy tales or chose to take
everything with a grain of salt the only
people who knew the truth about what
went on in foreign countries were the
ones who had seen these places with
their own eyes at a time when traveling
meant going on a journey that required
sailing walking or horseback riding
people could only go so far before they
ran out of money food and water so the
only people who really traveled the
world were the merchants they had
generations of their families maps and
personal experiences behind them it took
an entire lifetime to repair for the
journey Marco Polo grew up learning to
read write and speak multiple languages
while his father and uncle were gone his
mother passed away and he spent a lot of
his time at home eagerly waiting for his
father and uncles returned so that they
could go on an adventure together
by the time niccolò and Maffeo finally
returned to Venice Marco Polo was 15
years old they told the boy that they'd
spent several years in Constantinople
before finding themselves assured into
China at the heart of the Mongolian
Empire the leader Kublai Khan was
interested in meeting them because it'd
never seen European men before the Khan
was impressed by their ability to read
and write in so many languages and he
believed that they could be very useful
to him the Polo brothers were treated as
esteemed guests and they were given
luxuries beyond their wildest dreams he
asked them to return to Italy on a
mission to meet
for Pope Kublai Khan had requested for
the Polo brothers to bring back 100
priests the Mongolian Empire Kublai Khan
was a Buddhist but he was very accepting
of all cultures and religions he wanted
Christians to come into his empire to
help diversify academic knowledge of the
kingdom unfortunately for the polos they
returned to find that the Vatican was
arguing over who would become the next
Pope
niccolò and Maffeo brought back gold and
gemstones that were hidden in the lining
of their clothes and they were able to
sell them for a small fortune for two
years they prepared to return to
Mongolia in TOR tamargo all about what
to expect on the journey without the
help of the Pope they could only
convince two priests to come with them
when Marco was 17 his father and uncle
packed up the caravan and so they set
off on a journey across the lands that
would take them a full three years
traveling from Italy to China was no
small task the polos had plans to take a
boat there but they realized that after
years of being away the family ship had
fallen into disrepair and there would be
no way for them to sail they had no
choice but to go on foot if they went
straight through the desert they would
never make it so they had to go on a
journey where they were able to stop at
small cities and Oasis along the way
they would have taken camels horses and
donkeys to help carry the supplies they
ate dried meat and drank water and once
they reached a town or city they would
barter with their goods to trade for
fresh fruits and vegetables in the
marketplaces all along the way they
carried goods that they could sell for a
profit in the next country the journey
would have been exhausting and they
would have been exposed to brutal
elements but there were also countless
numbers of bandits waiting to steal from
travelling caravans Marco Polo mentions
the Tatars who were known to kill men
without mercy
but the Polo family was gifted with
golden passports which provided them
protection from the Great Khan it was
written this if anyone were to mess with
the polos they would have to face the
wrath of Khan's entire army because of
this he never mentions going through
many hardships during their journey
except for the fact that the two priests
similarly couldn't handle it they were
forced to turn back and return to Italy
the polis had to cross over the Pamir
mountains in south-central Asia
he describes the bitter
and how their fires were never as hot as
they were back home the next big
challenge was the Gobi Desert where they
periodically came across the skeletons
of dead animals and humans who had not
survived the harsh conditions he often
heard the singing sand dunes he
described it as sounding like different
instruments playing all at once and
sometimes it sounded like the dunes were
whispering his name it was enough to
drive a man mad there were stories of
men wandering into the desert to try and
find the source of the music that they
never returns now this story truly does
sound supernatural because it was as if
some vengeful spirit was trying to lure
the men into the desert but this is
actually a very real phenomenon these
musical notes come from these sounds of
vibrations of sand sliding down the
dunes they play the musical notes GE or
F which some people have described as
sounding similar to a cello once Marco
Polo reached China he became very ill
and was afraid that he might actually
die but he found mountains that were
said to have magical healing powers and
he climbs the mountain breathed in the
fresh air and found that it truly did
heal him he wrote that in Tibet parents
wanted their daughters to have sex with
as many men as possible before they got
married so that they could prove how
desirable they would be as wives since
he was a young European man these
parents were practically throwing their
daughters at him to have a foreigner
review their daughter's sexual abilities
he mentions that Tibet was a great place
to be for a boy who was 17 to 20 years
old
of course this story caused a bit of
controversy and it was one of the many
examples of the stories that people
found too far-fetched to believe but it
is actually based on a real custom now
just before we get into the second half
for today's video let me tell you a bit
about Vince Sarah watches I am wearing
one of these watches right now this is a
Vince arrow chronograph as well as
keeping perfect time it's also got a
timer and these three back dials here
they don't just look great they also
serve that timer function now I picked
out a watch from Vince area with a blue
and silver combination but there are
loads of different options on their
website you're sure to find something
that suits your style and also they'll
accommodate your wrist size
I have small wrists say they manage to
get me a smaller watch which is
fantastic it fits great on me now I've
put this watch through its paces and
it's still looking as
as the day I got it super durable the
watch itself also the leather strap in
fact the leather strap doesn't look new
it kind of has that nice aged leather
look it gets a little bit softer a
little bit better I really like that now
in Sarah watches they believe that
luxury isn't about price or
specification it's about detail and
craftsmanship and then Sarah watches
they've got a ton of that unlike many
other watches on the market this isn't
about minimalist style you've seen those
watches this isn't that it's more about
the classic look of a good watch further
by selling direct to the consumer Vince
Eric and deliver a great watch for a
much better price than you might expect
go check out the full range at than
Sarah watches com forward slash and bio
graphics and use the code biographic
song' check out for a special discount
thanks to Vince area Watchers for
sponsoring let's get back to it
[Music]
years before Marco Polo was born a
powerful leader named Genghis Khan
United the Mongolian Empire once all of
the Mongol tribes were led by a single
leader they began to conquer surrounding
territories in Asia Eastern Europe and
the Middle East
Mongolian Warriors were trained since
they were toddlers to ride on horseback
and the men spent their entire lives
preparing a battle they simply had the
strongest army in the world with
millions of soldiers prepared to fight
for the Khan in each new generation the
strongest heir was chosen to be the new
Khan Marco Polo and his family they were
keen to see could blind Khan who was
arguably one of the greatest rulers the
Empire had ever seen after traveling
over 10,000 miles Marco niccolò and
Maffeo polo all arrived Bligh Khan's
Summer Palace they were all greeted as
esteemed royal guests even though he had
heard so many stories from his father
and uncle it could never compare to
experiencing the real thing Marco Polo
was completely blown away by the wealth
and magnificence of the Mongolian Empire
the palace was massive and had its own
Park with lush gardens and exotic
species of animals living on the lands
even in the 1200 s the Chinese had
advanced systems of heating and cooling
that had never seen in Europe pipes in
the grounds heated the polished hardwood
floors which kept the royal court warm
in the winter engineers had constructed
impressive buildings and bridges further
their sanitation systems were also years
ahead of Europe everyone was clean they
smell good and they dressed in luxurious
silk robes shimmering with golden
threats for Marco Polo it was like he
simply died and gone to heaven the corn
threw a celebration for the Polo
family's arrival man they had a huge
feast they fed over 40,000 guests and
Marco Polo could fill his cup with
unlimited drinks from a massive silver
wine fountain he was incredibly
impressed with Kublai Khan polo hooked
up to him with an almost godlike
reverence because he was an example of
the perfect ruler the Great Khan had
incredible skill in battle like his
ancestors before him but he was also
educated and level-headed when it came
to making diplomatic decisions instead
of attempting to rule every single
country that he conquered Kublai Khan
allowed existing government structures
to continue functioning on their own so
long as they agreed to bow down to the
Khan and
pledge their allegiance to the Mongolian
Empire this meant that every territory
was allowed to keep their religions
their languages and their culture Kublai
Khan he celebrated diversity and he
believes that one day the Mongolian
Empire would spread across the entire
planet because of this it was very
important to have advisors like the Polo
family in his court to help him
negotiate with foreign nations Marco
Polo became one of Kublai Khan's trusted
advisors and he was able to live among
the royal court since he could speak
five languages he was very useful in
diplomacy and negotiations
he was eventually trusted to be in
charge of the Mongolian salt trade and
brokered deals for sending the mineral
to other lands at that time salts it was
incredibly valuable even though it was
relatively easy to produce he described
in great detail about how the workers
made salt from boiling seawater in giant
vats which is a technique that is still
used in China today along with all of
these responsibilities Marco Polo was an
out to enjoy all of the best
entertainment that the Empire to offer
there were musical performances horse
races theater and wrestling matches men
of high standing were allowed to have
their own harem as well the most
beautiful women in the empire were all
brought to the palace he wrote about how
the women were skilled in playing
musical instruments and how they were
all graceful and polite keep in mind
that he was just 20 years old when he
arrived and he had already had so much
experience being the most popular guy in
Tibet during his journey to China while
it's not included in his book there is
one Chinese Court record from that time
that is believed to be about Marco Polo
a foreign man was arrested because he
was walking with a woman alone at night
without an escort this was illegal but
the young man was totally unaware of the
law and he had diplomatic immunity so
they simply let him go but not all of
the women in the Mongolian Empire were
there for the men's entertainment market
polo witnessed Kublai Khan's nice
princess could he Yunnan battle for her
right to choose her own husband she set
out a challenge that if any man could
defeat her in wrestling they would win
her hand in marriage however no one was
ever able to defeat her and she acquired
a massive fleet of ten thousand horses
she was allowed to remain unmarried and
fought alongside her father in battle
even without polos helped keep her
memory alive good a unit Ori was so
incredible that it has been passed down
by word of mouth in China for
hundreds of years
the scholars believe that the polos
would have been afraid of what would
have happened to them after Kublai
Khan's death since they were foreigners
who were not official citizens of the
empire they may not have had the same
rights and privileges once he passed
away they claimed that they were
homesick and Hundley requested to return
to Italy the calm though he found them
very useful and at first he didn't want
to see them go but eventually he
relented saying that they could leave as
long as they escorted a woman named
princess Kaka chin to meet her new
husband in Persia
she was also called of a blue princess
and she was remembered for her legendary
beauty this time they did not have to go
through the harsh mountains and desert
they were able to take a boat to Persia
but over 100 people they died on the
journey only eighteen survived including
the polos and the princess by the time
he returned to Italy Marco Polo had been
gone for 24 years and he was a bachelor
in his 40s during the war between Genoa
and Venice Marco Polo was arrested and
the government illegally seized the
majority of his wealth that he had
acquired in his time away he was able to
hide some of his gold and gemstones but
he was truly lucky that his book was a
best-seller otherwise he may have ended
up broke after all of those years away
as we mentioned before Marco Polo told
these stories to Arista chello and yes
he never describes himself for very much
of his personal life throughout the
entire book Marco Polo is acting more
like a journalist or a non-biased
observer he passes no personal judgments
and he simply explains the things that
he was seeing in a very matter-of-fact
way after publishing the travels of
Marco Polo the author got mixed reviews
some people congratulated him for his
accomplishments while others accused him
of being a liar many of the stories
challenged Christian beliefs about the
outside world and by comparison the
Mongolian Empire seemed superior to
Europe in a number of ways there were
wealthy they were powerful well-educated
open-minded and had the strongest army
in the world these stories made some
Europeans feel inadequate by comparison
and they clung onto their ethnocentric
worldview in modern times
scholars have poured over the original
manuscript of Marco Polo's books and
compared it to details of ancient
Chinese documents they were able to
confirm nearly every detail being
correct which proves that he was telling
the truth all along for the rest of his
life market polo tried to ignore the
haters and he
went on living his life he got married
to a Venetian noblewoman and they had
three daughters together in the records
of his oldest daughters dowry it was
documented that he passed on the golden
passport that he received from the Khan
in 1324 Marco Polo was on his deathbed
surrounded by his family a priest showed
up to read him his last rites and he
urged polo to confess if he had truly
lied about his stories as a way of
cleansing his soul his dying words were
that he only told a fraction of all the
stories about his amazing experiences
and if he had given away all of the
stories in the book it would blow
everyone's mind since no one would have
believed him anyway as the years went on
there would be several new editions of
Marco Polo's books priests rewrote his
stories with a Christian slant so that
they could bolster Europe's superiority
they highlighted certain stories like
the women in Tibet as examples of the
East sinfulness and depravity they still
could not stand the idea that China was
just somehow better than Europe
unfortunately future generations would
see this altered manuscripts and take it
as a sign that white people needed to
reform foreign natives with Christianity
future explorers like Christopher
Columbus used this altered version of
Marco Polo's book as a guide for his own
journey however he often got it wrong
believing that they had landed in an
entirely different country without the
ability to speak the language Columbus
assumes that he had landed in India and
immediately set out to enslave the
native people he colonized the lands for
conquest and greed rather than
attempting to assimilate or understands
the Native American language and culture
now people love the story of Marco Polo
that no one truly knows what he looks
like there are any artists
interpretations of how they imagined him
even though he had so many stories to
tell we know very little about the
actual man we don't even really know
what he did on a day-to-day basis or
anything about his personality despite
the fact that we know so little about
who he truly was he is still considered
to be one of the most admired people in
history not just for his discoveries but
because he lived his life to the fullest
extent he was able to experience seeing
a new world that was unlike anything
that Europe had ever seen before and he
became the real-life hero of every story
about that one special person who is
invited to a magical world and that in a
way is what dreams are made of so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe
got brand-new videos just like this
several times a week also if you think
there's something else to watch right
now why not check out my other channel
called today I found out you'll find a
link to that on the screen now as well
as below this video and as always thank
you for watching
you
[Music]